there's zach lowers numbers on the year
making his ninth appearance his fifth
career big league start he's been much
better as a reliever than he has a start
two strikes against
tavares and lather with a good beginning
striking him out
three and two kinder philanthropic
second base after that wild pitch moved
him up and he gets another strike out
there it was that fastball and so he's
got two k's
in the first three batters he's seen now
they're seeing maybe strike out the
sound in this first inning
strike three three strikeouts in the
first inning for zach lowther and he
strands connor falefa after an infield
single we go to the bottom of the first
inning in baltimore glenn otto finishing
up his warm-up tosses as he gets ready
to make the fifth start of his career
he's one short now becoming the first
ever 30-30 player in baltimore history
the 1-2
beauty strike three call
and otto strikes him out looking and the
payoff pitch struck came out swinging
with a slider back to back strikeouts
for otto here in the bottom of the first
inning brings up trey mancini 2-2 and he
swings and misses strike three otto
strikes out the side
two on none out and dj peters will bat
for the rangers there's one two
swing and a miss got him on a curveball
down and in here comes jonah heim
somebody used to have orioles ties
swing and a miss another nasty hook down
and in and lather has struck out five
out of five ouch recorded to start the
game two on two out
and a little chopper right side lather
off the mound to grab it run to first
flip to mount castle and there is the
first out on a ball in play out of nine
outs recorded in the game ryan mckenna
will lead off for baltimore in the
bottom of the second one-two pitch and
that is strike three called and how
about that glen otto
with four strikeouts jones a 164 battery
he's only had 59 at bats one two strike
three called and he has struck out five
in an inning and two thirds strikeout
competition is on it's also the third
strikeout looking tonight otto trying to
make it
six in the first two innings
and a bouncer
left side of the infield and abanez
throws out martin the inning is done no
score top three now they're strong so
far
he went all the way around
add another strikeout to louder's total
tonight andy abunas
in the air to left field
hayes jogs in he makes the catch the
orioles set up runners at the corners
with two outs and here's hayes who's
singled to right his first time up get
high into the air down the right field
line garcia coming in across the line in
foul ground makes the catch along the
track
and hayes is the final out here in the
home third no score here at camden yards
zach lowther and glen otto locked up in
a pitchers duel
rolled on the ground to shortstop right
at richie martin
and he'll take care of garcia one out
nick scholak
on a line into center fian mullins
racing on he gets there so cedric
mullins reads it well
solac denied a hit and they're two outs
as dj peters now bats the one-two pitch
another curveball in the dirt this one
does get away from wins he retrieves it
fires second base out he gunned down low
what a play by austin wins trying to
advance on the ball that ricocheted off
austin wins to his left and he retrieved
it and then gunned him down at second
base and the innie ends and richie
martin will now bat with mckenna at
third jones at first
two and one against richie martin runner
bluffs bun is set down otto has no play
at the plate they'll throw to first and
so richie martin he's got the budding
skills and he uses them to give the
orioles a one-nothing lead as mckenna
comes down to score one-two pitch here
and that's in there for a call third
strike fastball we're the outer half and
gutierrez is the final out here in the
bottom half of the fourth inning
peters will lead off the fifth inning
2-2
breaking ball strike three
slider on the outside corner strikeout
number seven for zach lowther extending
his career-high number 2-0
hit on the ground to shortstop richie
martin will throw on the first and it's
just in time to get the speedy tavares
here's austin wins the number nine
batter one and two on the pitch swinging
in the miss on a breaking ball there's
one down in the bottom of the fifth the
oreos lead one to nothing as otto has
tied his career high for strikeouts in
the game mount castle has gone one for
two in the game today 30 home runs for
mel castle 30 home runs for adolesce
garcia
fastball crack to right field way deep
no chance garcia is going to get to this
it is gone one hop to the fence
protecting the flag court from utah
street and ryan mount castle has just
taken sole possession of the major
league home run rookie lead he breaks a
tie with adoles garcia who stood in
right field and watched it fly over his
head
number 31 for ryan and the orioles lead
two nothing two outs
scoring position for texas
chopped
over the mound martin coming in throws
him out at first well done by richie
martin helping baumann out mike falmouth
in his second inning of relief against
the veteran hitter calhoun
he hits this one high in the air but
it'll stay in the ballpark mckenna
he has got it solac thought about
tagging but he's going to go back and
the rangers now have the tying run on
base the switch hitter leota tavares
will bat against coal soldier but now
there are two outs
broken back grounder out to second base
jones throws to first they get tavares
and coal salsa strands two men in
scoring positions this is the tougher
part of the texas lineup two three four
kinder follefa then embanks then garcia
to two
it's a strike and a fastball right down
the middle really
[Applause]
one one pitch to andy abanya sid of the
air to center mullins jogging in still
underneath it he makes the catch two
down two and two against garcia
and salsa pulled the string and struck
him out and salser strikes out the first
and last of a one two three eighth
inning austin hayes will bat orioles up
two nothing and looking to extend it 2-1
swing a high fly ball drilled left field
calhoun looks it is way out of here
number 22 hit by number 21. austin hayes
blasts to solo home run to deep left
field and makes it a three-nothing oreo
lead in the eighth so tyler wells two
outs recorded here in the ninth ending
to start and needs just one more
heim puts it in the air shallow left
racing on austin hayes
shutout complete orioles take down the
rangers by a final score of three to
nothing